we're counting down the top 20 stories
from the 2018 calendar year and at
number 20 one of the first stories from
the 2018 calendar in January divisional
round of the playoffs the Vikings
hosting the Saints the Vikings up 17
nothing in the third quarter they blow
the lead but when the Saints pull ahead
they pull ahead a little bit too early
because the Vikings had just enough time
to drive down the field and author one
of the all-time great plays in NFL
history will be known as the Minneapolis
miracle the touchdown pass from Case
Keenum to Stefon Diggs the Saints were
not in a very good defense and defensive
back Marcus Williams made a not very
good effort to tackle Stefon Diggs who
ran into the end zone pulled off his
helmet and throw it and it sparked
pandemonium in Minnesota and also it
created a very real sense the Vikings
could win the Super Bowl for the first
time in franchise history become the
first team that is hosting the Super
Bowl to play in it but it all fell apart
exactly a week later when the Vikings
went to Philadelphia and were blown off
the field by the use
we made the announcement that Josh was
gonna be our head football coach I got a
call Tuesday evening saying he had
decided to he changed his mind and was
going in a different direction we see
this from time to time in the hiring
cycle in January there's one team that
has yet to hire a coach and that team
doesn't because that team is waiting for
one of the assistant coaches who will be
working in the Super Bowl and this past
year everyone knew that Josh McDaniels
was earmarked to become the new coach of
the Indianapolis Colts and everyone
expected it to happen not long before
the Super Bowl oh there was a thought
that maybe josh mcdaniels was having
second thoughts about taking that job in
two days after the Patriots lost to the
Eagles the Colts lost McDaniels he
decided to stay with the Patriots and
the Colts ultimately relieved because
they wanted someone who was all-in and
Frank Reich tumbled into their lap after
helping the Eagles win the Super Bowl he
wasn't a serious candidate before
McDaniels bailed bright became the guy
who may very well be the right man for
the Colts for 2018 and many years to
come
one of the biggest surprises of the 2017
season in a good way became one of the
biggest surprises of the 2018 season in
a bad way the Jaguars within a whisker
of the Super Ball end up imploding in
2018 early on it looked like that wasn't
gonna happen
they were to a No they beat the patrons
but it all started to fall apart we saw
the warning signs late in the offseason
when Jalen Ramsey was quoted in a couple
of print interviews saying some fairly
inflammatory things that made us wonder
where is the discipline for this Jaguars
team that was founded on that concept
last year and as the season unfolded we
saw more and more examples of a lack of
discipline it created a problem that
resulted in the Jaguars plunging to the
basement of the AFC south and leaving
everyone to wonder which Jaguars team is
the real Jaguars team maybe we'll find
out in 2019 after several years of the
quarterback markets stagnating at the
top in the past couple of years more and
more quarterbacks have become the
highest-paid player in NFL history and
one continues to jump the other and it
culminated in Aaron Rodgers getting to a
whopping thirty three and a half million
per year not long before the start of
the 2018 season and then the 2018 season
began Rodgers was injured the Packers
looked good at times but struggled more
often than not and even when he became
healthy he wasn't the same guy we used
to sing and that's the big question
heading into 2019 the highest-paid
player in NFL history or his best days
in the rearview mirror and are we seeing
the beginning of the decline for one of
the best quarterbacks of all time
I mean anytime you lose your starting
quarterback in minutes everyone that is
a big deal
it's obviously feel for him personally I
know how disappointed he is oh my god
chance to see him yet the 49ers traded
in 2017 for quarterback Jimmy Garoppolo
after the season ended they made him the
highest-paid quarterback in NFL history
at the time three or four others have
passed him since then but there was
plenty of hope for a great 2018 for the
49ers hand for Garoppolo and in the
third game of the season while trying to
make a cut at the sideline so he could
deliver a blow to a defender who was
pursuing him he tore his ACL and was
lost for the year
throwing the 49ers into another season
of disarray there's plenty of hope for
2019 but the question for Jimmy
Garoppolo will always be can he stay
healthy so far when he's had chances to
play he hasn't been able to as
demonstrated most noticeably by the fact
that almost all of his 2018 season was
lost after a couple years of the ratings
for televised NFL games dropping
dramatically they rebounded in 2018 and
there's a good reason for it
it turns out that people like to watch
good games and they don't like to watch
bad games and they like to watch high
scoring games and they don't like to
watch low scoring games and the NFL has
noticed that the NFL has reveled in the
fact that scoring has been up throughout
the 2018 season and really has the NFL
plans for 2019 and beyond with new TV
contracts looming look for an FL to
subtly or not so subtly find ways to
encourage more scoring and to schedule
more good games for prime time windows
so more people will watch those games
and drive up the perceived value of the
NFL in the overall national landscape
where there are so many things out there
that can't attract our attention and
consume our time it's harder than ever
for the NFL to stand out but they've
realized so
James high-scoring that's what we'll do
[Music]
but I mean I'm definitely gonna look at
my future for sure
most sit down the next couple of weeks
and see where I'm at right now there was
a thought prior to the Super Bowl that
Patriots tight end Rob Gronkowski would
retire after the game and if the
Patriots beat the Eagles maybe he would
have instead he took several weeks to
make a decision about what he was going
to do for 2018 he ultimately decided to
play for the Patriots after the Patriots
in sport trading him and he went on to
have a 20-18 season that was far from
the standards he has set as recently as
2017 so what's next for Rob Gronkowski
he very well may retire in 2019 even if
he does play he's fallen very far from
the guy who used to be so dominant it
would dictate what a defense was doing
from a game planning standpoint now he's
just a guy you cover one-on-one like any
other tight end in the NFL and he's
performing like any other tight end in
the NFL which is a far cry from what
we're used to from Rob Gronkowski the
2018 draft saw five quarterbacks come
off the board in the first round and
they all eventually became starting
quarterbacks in their cities the last
one to be the full-time starter Lamar
Jackson pushing Joe Flacco as a
practical matter out of Baltimore but
all the other guys entrusted with that
opportunity to be the short-term answer
and the long-term franchise quarterback
Baker Mayfield looks to be the best of
the bunch so far but all will have long
careers all have their own unique skills
and all will be forming part of the
fabric of the NFL for seasons to come
I don't think it could have happened in
any better fashion than it did and to
have been that moment with my teammates
on the field the offensive line I mean
it just it played out even greater than
I ever could have imagined as drew Brees
closes in on his 40th birthday he had
one of his best seasons ever in 2018 and
it wasn't just because he set the
all-time career passing yardage mark is
because he played as well as he ever has
you know we focus so much on looking for
signs of slippage and Tom Brady here's
drew brees who isn't that much younger
than Brady still looking like the guy
he's always been and being a viable
candidate for his first ever League MVP
award it raises a real question as to
how long Brees will play he suggested
he's not gonna play until 45 but between
him and Tom Brady he could make the
argument that Brees is the guy who was
better suited to extending his career
halfway into his fifth decade the NFL
wanted us all to focus exclusively on
football in 2018 but there will still be
from time to time off field issues
sometimes multiple issues bubble up in a
fairly short time period like we saw
with Rubin Foster and Kareem hunt the
lingering challenge for the NFL is to
come up with investigative procedures
that are effective and that persuade the
public that the NFL knows what it's
doing when the time comes to figure out
what players have been doing when
they're not at work now when it comes to
video the NFL continues to fail in a
competition with TMZ to get videos that
the league knows are available and the
league is made it clear that it won't be
paying for video so moving forward look
for TMZ to continue to get the videos
that the NFL doesn't and when it comes
to actually confronting players with
allegations of wrongdoing the failure to
interview Kareem hunt for months is
something that the NFL was criticized
for and moving forward will be important
for the NFL to look at its procedures
and see how it can improve in order to
have more effective and fair
investigations of players accused of
offto of misconduct
I mean it was one of the most you know
competitive games I've been a part of
since I've been coaching in this league
I thought it was a really just a
competitive game with a lot of
high-caliber football and all three
phases the number 10 story for 2018 goes
10 times 10 plus 5 the 54-51 game from
Monday Night Football the game that was
supposed to be played in Mexico City
ended up in LA and ended up over
delivering on the very high expectations
that we all had we pegged it as game of
the year material in September by the
time the kickoff rolled around and by
the time that game ended it was every
bit as compelling and fascinating and as
exciting as we thought it would be it
caused some to think that defensive
football would die but defensive
football is still thriving and every
once in a while you get two great
offenses together and you get an outcome
like the one that we saw between the
Rams and the Chiefs and we may not see
another one like that anytime soon so
what do you do when you're the Minnesota
Vikings you get within a game of the
Super Bowl you've got three quarterbacks
under contract and they're all becoming
free agents you bring back none of them
and you make Kirk Cousins at the time
the highest-paid player in NFL history
at 28 million a year on a three-year
fully guaranteed contract it created
plenty of expectations in Minnesota and
I think the Vikings did enough to reel
those expectations in because the
schedules tougher the team is more of a
target they get their best from everyone
they see and what we've seen is a
Vikings franchise that has grossly under
in 2018 relative to that very special
season they had in 2017 and now moving
forward the question becomes can they
get more out of Kirk Cousins in the two
years that they are financially tied to
him
going into the 2018 season nobody really
knew what to make of the Chicago Bears
new head coach and Matt naggy new
approach offensively a quarterback in
Mitchell true Biscay who was entering
his second season but then came the
stunning decision to make a trade for
pass rusher Khalil Mack and even though
they gave up a lot to get him and
they're paying him even more than what
Aaron Donald makes in LA
Khalil Mack changed everything about
that Bears team changed the Bible
changed the expectation and thrust the
Bears into a position we didn't think
they would occupy for at least another
couple of years true and legitimate
playoff contender and possibly Super
Bowl contender and possibly a Super Bowl
contender for years to come
[Music]
frustrated mad don't like to lose like
that but this team will stick together
and they're just fighting we got a big
game that sticks as 2018 began the
Cleveland Browns inexplicably decided to
keep a head coach who had won 1 out of
32 games Hugh Jackson was going to get
one more opportunity to turn things
around and that opportunity ultimately
would not last long it became abundantly
clear early in the 2018 season that
there was too much dysfunction in the
organization between Hugh Jackson and
the offensive coordinator in Todd Haley
that some believe the Browns required
Jackson to hire they butted heads from
the first episode of hard knocks
onward and it ultimately came to a
climax in late October and Hugh Jackson
is out and what happened after that
the Browns began to play a lot better
and in the first five games without Hugh
Jackson they won as many games as they
won in the 40 games with him and the end
result is the future is bright for the
Cleveland Browns they've got a great
young quarterback in Baker Mayfield the
coach they hire in 2019 will go a long
way toward determining how quickly this
team becomes a true contender but take
heart Browns fans you've waited a long
time you're very soon going to have a
team that you can believe in
we didn't look back I can't tell you
what a celebration I had my mind we got
it done we need him
sure need another saver of his stature
the Dallas Cowboys spent a lot of time
in 2018 defending their decision to not
have a number one receiver and then they
got desperate and decided they better go
find a number one receiver well there
aren't many number one receivers
available they traded for Amari Cooper
who hadn't been playing like a number
one receiver for the Oakland Raiders and
at first with the Cowboys it didn't look
like it was going to be a great marriage
but then it exploded and Amari Cooper
became one of the best receivers in the
NFL vindicating the trade and also
setting himself up for a major payday
from the Cowboys in 2019 and what it did
is it helped spark this team to win
after win after win thrusting them into
the playoff conversation saving the job
most likely of head coach Jason Garrett
and giving the Cowboys a receiver to
compliment a great young quarterback in
back Prescott and a great young running
back in Ezekiel Elliott
[Music]
as the 2017 season was coming to a
conclusion it seemed more and more
inevitable that Jon Gruden would be
returning to the sidelines from the
broadcast booth and it looked like the
Buccaneers were the team that was going
to hire Jon Gruden after they put him in
the Ring of Honor and that sparked his
desire to come back in coach
enter Marc Davis in the Oakland Raiders
with that reported 10-year 100 million
dollar contract it's not it's not really
that but it's close enough to get Bruton
to go to Oakland and created a ton of
expectations as to what he would do
there his introductory press conference
was inspiring it was riveting and it
created expectations they would figure
things out
and they haven't sparked by a very
difficult negotiation with Khaleel Mac
that ultimately forced the Raiders to
trade him the season disintegrated
quickly for Jon Gruden and now they're
rebuilding at a time when they had a
playoff caliber roster under GM Reggie
McKenzie they're picking up the pieces
looking for a new GM and figure out
where they go from here
I've never been in this spot and I'm not
an act like I know what the hell I'm
gonna do tomorrow when they get in here
so we're gonna do roads they're gonna
represent the Packers we're glad to know
that so other than that we'll we'll
focus on with some photos in 99 prior
seasons of football the Green Bay
Packers had never fired a coach during
the season they had one coach leave
voluntarily in the middle of a campaign
this year season 100 became the first
time the Packers fired a guy with games
left Mike McCarthy gone after a
lackluster home performance against the
Cardinals had stunned the National
Football League and it sparked a debate
over whether or not McCarthy had done
enough in his time with the team to
deserve to have the right to finish the
season the Packers thought hey we know
what we're going to do when the season
ends we may as well go ahead and do it
it gives us a chance to start looking
for a new coach it gives McCarthy a
chance to figure out what he's going to
do next but others believe that he
should have had the chance to finish the
year on his own terms either way the
Packers decided they were finished with
Mike McCarthy and one of the big
questions for 2019 will be who to the
Packers find to take this place
I have no reaction I've told you guys
and I've told you guys consistently a
reaction comes from me if and when he
walks in the door until that happens I'm
business as usual focus on those that
are here and working and appropriately
so that way I don't waste my time and
theirs it's not very often that a player
in his prime will sit out all of an NFL
season especially when that player is
laid on bail and he's got 14 and a half
million dollars he's walking away from
but that's what Belle did in a
week-by-week drama that played out
throughout the course of the season
would he show up will he not show up and
eventually he didn't show up by the
deadline that came the Tuesday after
week 10
the Steelers had to go with James Connor
lady on Bell takes the year off and now
the question becomes when he hits the
open market in 2019 and hit the open
market he most likely will what kind of
money will he make and will it offset
the 14 and a half million that he
sacrificed by not playing football for
the Steelers or anyone else in 2018
it's a golden age for quarterbacks in
the National Football League and in 2018
we saw a great collection of guys on the
wrong side of 35 plus a new set of star
quarterbacks on the right side of 25 and
the best of the bunch
Patrick mahomes this is a guy who is
doing things we have never seen from an
NFL quarterback with no-look passes
sidearm throws because of his baseball
and basketball experiences he doesn't
need to have that that base that
mechanics that we hear about all the
time when it comes to quarterback play
he can make any throw from any angle
he's going to inspire a generation of
kids who will play quarterback like him
and he's going to be around for a
generation legitimate MVP candidate and
a guy who is going to be one of the best
quarterbacks that we see in the National
Football League for however long he can
play and it could be for a very long
time
and the top story for 2018 the
Philadelphia Eagles win their first
Super Bowl ever their first championship
since 1960 with a couple of home wins in
the playoffs where they were the
underdogs and they broke out the
underdog masks with Nick Foles at
quarterback instead of Carson Wentz and
then they go to the Super Bowl and with
Malcom Butler and explicably standing on
the sidelines for nearly all of the game
for the New England Patriots made
mincemeat of the New England defense and
outscored Tom Brady and company vaulting
Falls and Doug Peterson to the
championship and sparking a year-long
celebration in Philadelphia which
unfortunately has not translated into a
stellar 2018 season but it doesn't
matter you finally got your Super Bowl
trophy live it up Philadelphia
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports